when she's mighty thor she's six foot
and like you know jacked and to
understand what that might be to go
through the world like that i think is
you know was really an amazing
opportunity as a very petite person
[Music]
it was incredible to get to play this uh
powerful superhero you know it's it's
rare i think to
get these kind of opportunities in
general and particularly as a woman it's
also it's even rarer so um it was really
it felt really lucky and i i kept
thanking tyka every day i was like this
is so cool
he makes it his mission to make sure
everyone has like the best day possible
every day you know he's djing he's on
the mic trying to make everyone laugh
um he does like crew workouts where he
you know every hour on the hour there's
like crew squats and
push-ups and
um
so it's just like it really i really
understood how you can create like a
vibe on set that makes everyone excited
to come to work every day and i think
that that's
um really really
just incredible well i think it's really
wonderful those conversations are
happening because i think the
conversations are what has been
propelling
the expansion of this and the
normalization of it like i think that's
really
lit the fire under all the people in
power um you know to
make more films with
central female characters to make more
superheroes that are female but yes i
pray for the day when it's completely
normalized and we don't have to talk
about it and it's just you know the way
things are i i look forward to that day
but i appreciate until
it really is
kind of just the way of the world i
appreciate that people are still
propelling the conversation
it's incredible and i i see the effect
um on my kids of getting to grow up in a
world where there are
characters that represent all of
humanity and all of the range of human
possibility and i see that how different
it is the way they're growing up versus
the way i grew up the actual uh
entertainment and creative expression
that people are putting out into the
world i think it shows them that
they can
be you know they have the full range of
possibility for who they want to be who
they want to love
it was really fun to get to play
um first of all both sides of this
character that there's this superhero
kind of like
tough badass side and there's also very
human vulnerable
self-doubting fearful side and then also
to have
this character
become big you know she when she's
mighty thor she's six foot and like you
know jacked and
so to understand what that might be to
go through the world like that i think
is you know was really an amazing
opportunity as a very petite person
and then to
think what what does it mean to take up
as much space as possible what does it
feel like to walk into a room and see
over everyone's head and
be able to kind of control and have
people be intimidated by you that it's
just a very different way of walking
through the world also there's no hiding
you know like i can walk into a room and
kind of like no one pays attention but
when you're that big you know
chris hemsworth walks into a room and he
can't help but everyone looks at him
just he's an imposing figure of course
also very well known but um first step
is recognizing the influence of this
kind of pressure to take up as little
space as possible which i think
is kind of like a female
message we we get you know with all the
like be tiny be tiny
of course i mean the recent supreme
court decision around that has taken
away women's right to make their own
decisions about their health care
because abortion is healthcare is
clearly um
you know
devastating to live in a country
uh where your personhood is not is is
not given the same
um treatment as as others i think that
that's been probably the most blatant
infuriating
um
example of just feeling like you're in
you you live in a country that that
doesn't doesn't value you and your
agency and your autonomy in any way
i feel like the past decade has been
like a real like learning process of
learning
how to use my voice and seeing so much i
think uh learning so much from being in
community with other women those kinds
of sharing
conversations with other women that i
work with
that's been really really i think
probably the most
like had the biggest impression on me in
terms of learning to to use my voice i
think early on
that
i went to college i feel like a lot of
people were kind of like why are you
going to college and that was really
amazing for me to kind of get this first
of all like
life experience and learning experience
and also
the group of friends that has sustained
me to this day of you know just
incredible people who are doing all
different things and then i think having
a family
um while working
also just gave me a complete new first
of all appreciation and understanding
for every working parent
but also
um
gave me a new relationship to my work
sometimes the limitations i've had of
like oh i need to shoot things that only
happen during my kids school vacations
in the city where i live you know
have actually
led me to creative experiences i might
not have otherwise taken on because um
like always sometimes your creative
limitations like bring you the uh
the kind of breakthroughs as well oh
yeah i mean i definitely
feel
like i know myself better than any other
which i mean i should hope for everyone
that at the moment they are they know
themselves better than they did
before but yeah there's always the
feeling of like ah if i could just be 20
again knowing what i know about myself
now you know could really
take advantage of that moment much
better
well it just makes you exercise kind of
different aspects of yourself because
you know you obviously
a lot of what you do as an actor is
being quite fluid and working to help
create someone else's vision namely your
director and i love that and obviously
advocating for your character and what
you think creatively but also working
within someone else's structure which i
love and then
um you know when you are producing or
directing or
running a business you're in
more of uh creating the structure kind
of position and um and you know dealing
with things that come up and
you know putting out fires and there's
it's a different level of responsibility
so um it's been it's been really
interesting to kind of find those parts
of myself